we're continuing this discussion
of whether it's reasonable
to go to someone of a certain identity
to ask questions about that identity how
did it start well last week i got a
voicemail or maybe it was monday now i
don't remember last week or monday i got
a voicemail from someone saying hey
david
i have some jewish questions yiddish
actually what's the schmeckle what's a
shekel and i answered them
and then on tuesday the eggman called in
and said david that that's inappropriate
that's anti-semitic it's like going to a
black woman and asking her to touch her
hair and i said i don't think so i think
it's logical that you would go to people
that you believe might have more
knowledge about something than you and
you ask them about it as long as it's
being done in good faith uh but the
eggman didn't like that we have a new
voicemail caller this we're going
through every identity we had a jewish
man call in the egg man to give his
perspective now a gay man called in to
say he welcomes people asking him
questions about homosexuality take a
listen to this
hey david this is rich from palm springs
california and i was just listening to
your piece uh
where you played the eggman saying that
he thought it was disrespectful to ask
you about uh jewish
languages and sayings and such
and i agree with you i think he's wrong
as a gay man i have no problem answering
questions i find a lot of straight
people have questions about gay
lifestyle and
terms and stuff like that and they're
truly curious but they're not going to
sit at home and google stuff um i mean
maybe they would but that's not really
an issue and as long as it's respectful
and not just like some ignorant jerk
being an ignorant jerk yeah so what what
i think is inappropriate is once i was
at um once i was at a a brunch this was
so awkward i was at a brunch
and
someone
upon fine it was like a round passover
time at some other some other year
around passover time
and completely unprovoked just on the
basis of figuring out i was jewish from
from uh
mentioning having been at passover
this woman says to me in a very
antagonistic way
can you explain to me
why the u.s government sends money to
israel
and
it's
it's like i'm expected as a jewish
person
to defend the foreign policy of the
united states
and it was clearly bad faith it was
clearly antagonistic it's like going to
i don't know is it going to a muslim
person and saying can you defend why the
u.s sends money to pakistan or egypt or
something like that
that's completely bad faith it was a
completely inappropriate question i
don't know i'm not the spokesperson for
that
why are you asking me
um
but it's different that someone says hey
what is what is what's schmeckle do you
know what schmeckle is
i think that's okay and i think it is
all it is all context as the caller
points out we have a great bonus show
for you today
ukraine says russia's offensive in the
donbas has begun and is rapidly
escalating we're going to talk about it
florida governor ron desantis is trying
to strip disney of self-governing power
that doesn't sound like letting
businesses do what they want we'll talk
about it and sarah palin as we've said
she's trying a comeback she's running
for a member of the house
but she's running up against the problem
which is that her star power seems to
have dramatically dimmed in her home
state of alaska can she still win we'll
talk about it all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show how do you
get the bonus show it's very easy you go
to joinpackman.com and you sign up
and instantly you'll be able to listen
to the bonus show
or watch the bonus show whichever is
your preference if you're more an audio
person you can listen if you're more a
video person you can watch you could
also play the video but only listen to
it
i don't know why you would do that but
you could
sign up at joinpackman.com we'll see you
then